we're currently witnessing often violent
protests in countless countries across
the world people are talking about a new
global political awakening but what are
the protesters have in common
and where will the angry uprisings lead
outrage over corrupt regimes are
yearning not to be shut out economically
or politically people want justice and
they want freedom it may only be minor
grievances that trigger a movement but
the impact can be huge and it might even
change our world so our question is
protests across the globe talking about
a revolution
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on to the point and here with me
in the studio today
raghida Burnham from Lebanon who says we
are witnessing a global youth rebellion
not seen since 1968 and people in the
Middle East are finally breaking the
fear barrier also with this is Rick
Nowak from The Washington Post who
argues that protesters share their
frustrations with political systems that
don't work in their favor but the
solutions to their concerns often differ
vastly and the warm welcome to to eunice
Grimm Research Associates at the
Institute for protest and social
movement studies here in Berlin who
believes that the global protests
underlined the level of frustration
among younger generations about the
failure of elites to come up with
answers to the problems of our time
thank you all three for being here today
once again we're going to begin with
raghida and you know we can make a list
of countries that are taking part in
these uprisings these protests you know
Hong Kong Lebanon Catalonia Chile for
example Iraq for example I could go on
with an endless almost list there are a
lot of people who think that these
movements and these protests have
something in common that they overlap
that they they have something in common
let's stick with that do you agree well
they do have something in common
actually more than one thing maybe
firstly it's led by young people and
it's leaderless I mean in all those
places we have now almost of those
places we have not seen protest led by
leaders or led by people who are telling
those young people to demonstrate to go
on the streets and to demand each one
maybe are demanding different things but
they're all on the street
angry wanting the political elite to
listen to their demands but yeah they're
all young they all want better future
for themselves and they're not following
any leader and the unrest is spreading
in the Arab world too reminiscent of the
Arab Spring nearly a decade ago to what
extent do you see this as something
you and different possibly something
even more potent well I would say it's
very different from what happened in the
what was called the Arab Spring because
if we look at what's happening in Iraq
and Lebanon now for example people for
the first time are going out on the
street not for support of the political
leaders but actually against them I mean
we see people who used in Lebanon who
used to go on the street in support of
Hezbollah who are now protesting against
Hezbollah or ago you used to go in the
street and support of Rafael Hariri the
the Sunni prime minister are now or they
you they were demanding his resignation
and he resigned and the same with the
Christian leaders and in Iraq as well we
see people asking the leaders that they
elected a few months ago to resign and
you know to elect a new government that
does not have anything to do with
political figures but bureaucrats I
recognize once again just for a moment
about the common factors I've got one
expert who says that this has got to do
with elite worldwide failing to give
people the feeling that they can look
forward to a life of hope and
self-respect is that the common
denominator there you see there
certainly is that element a lot of
especially younger people feel fed up
with essentially political systems or
structures that were imposed on down
sometimes years ago sometimes decades
ago which they feel do now no longer
work for them essentially and what's
also interesting I think is that a lot
of cases those protesters do not
necessarily identify with a political
party they don't no longer they do not
um feel represented by it by analytical
parties any longer and that's certainly
something I've I've observed also
looking at Latin America for instance
the Middle East and Yanis just pick up
on that point if you would a global
change movement is what is what is being
described a period of flux not seen for
decades does that capture that zeitgeist
yeah I mean I'm a bit uneasy about that
notion that basically we're seeing
something completely new and nothing has
been going on in the last year's
basically so I think that is part of the
truth and we're definitely seeing a
spike of protests and in parts of the
world that were not affected by protests
in the past such as some of the
republics that were
I missed by the Arab Spring let's put it
like that but then at the same time also
with that new attention on some of the
hot spots comes also more attention more
media attention to other hot spots in
the world which you know I said it
spirals up into you know into a media
frenzy of protests a media frenzy
because the media but many other people
ordinary people that I've been beating
in recent weeks are saying we're
approaching some kind of tipping point I
think people are empowered by the
pictures they see from other parts of
the world that that you know are
televised on there they come to their
home screens they they you know appear
in their social media they see what is
happening there and suddenly they you
know there's a shift of mindset there's
impression maybe we could try something
alike here you know and maybe some of
the recipes for the same problems that
we have social injustice corruption etc
maybe some of these recipes might as
well work in our context so this I think
there's a there's a powerful contagion
element but that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's all a global movement
because in the end it's multi causal I
think the factors that drive these
protests okay you're nodding yeah I
think that's absolutely correct because
obviously we always tend to draw
comparisons and that's helpful
especially when it comes to trying to
look for solutions like what can we
learn from other countries how to how to
respond to this or how how to address
those demands but at the same time
Barcelona and what's been happening
there is hardly comparable to to what's
happening in happening in Iraq right now
the commentators have been pointing to
us presidential advisor and and
academics he was big neoprene ski
talking of a few years ago about a
global political awakening that notion
of an awakening is very optimistic about
what we're seeing
do you share that kind of optimism well
I would say this is more backlash
against deteriorating conditions it's
not necessarily wakening in a sense I
think ten years ago or a few years ago
we saw people being inspired by progress
and and them protesting because they
wanted to be part of it um and they felt
left out I think what we're seeing a lot
of places now is actually quite
different it's more a backlash against
things getting worse for them and for
for their country's overall
think people are getting emboldened when
they see other people in other countries
where it wasn't thought about that they
could go on the streets and and protest
against their leaders they're doing it
and they starts thinking well if they're
doing it maybe we can do it I mean the
protest if we take an example between
Iraq and 11 and the demonstrators were
holding banners saying what we salute
the protesters in Iraq and so the other
way around also in the Iraq they were
saying we salute the protesters in
Lebanon so when the people in Lebanon
saw that the people in Iraq are on the
streets actually burning the trying to
burn the Iraqi the Iranian embassy
because they feel that Iran is
interfering in their affairs and is one
of the reasons why it's it's holding the
country back so the people who support
his brother in Lebanon in its Fiesta and
this house thought okay if they're doing
that well maybe we can also voice our
our opinion and go in the street and and
demand you know better better living for
us I mean the situation in the Iraq 11
is still not comparable in terms of
violence that has seen as Iraq has seen
but you know that there's always this
danger that things can can slide out of
control but definitely there's this link
that people see each other especially in
the social media age where everything is
posted immediately and people can you
know send each other pictures of what's
happening and they can follow on
Facebook and Twitter what's going on so
people do feel emboldened by that okay
we've got three examples of the moment
in each instance when outraged in
despair boiled over into protests and
sometimes into violence Chile a four
cent hike in subway fares triggered mass
protests president sebastián piñera a
billionaire was made a scapegoat when
images surfaced of Panera dining in an
expensive restaurant
protesters blamed the government for the
ever widening gap between rich and poor
Lebanon tens of thousands took to the
streets condemned a 20 cent per day fee
the government planned to impose on
telephone poles over the internet in
late October Prime Minister al-hariri
resigned but the protests continued now
they're directed against the
government's economic policies
corruption and inflation France every
Saturday tens of thousands across the
country protested against a 7 cent
increase in fuel prices after two months
the government rolled back the price
increases here too the demonstrations
have continued taking aim at social
inequalities in spring 2019 the movement
lost steam after president Immanuel
McCoy initiated a national debate our
people today more willing to fight for
their rights well that's a good question
but they're Yanis it was all about
grievances surrounding mobility and
communication what does that tell us
about the movements that were sort of
witnessing at this point in time I would
say that it's often the triggers are
often maybe not only mobility and and
and telecommunications but basically
subluxation basically so it's because
these are sectors where corruption is
rampant in many parts of the world and
where all kinds of social classes are
affected in a way by this so basically
and especially the ones that are that
are anyway the the disenfranchised of
the globalization and and of liberal
economic reforms and so on so what I
think is all right what I believe is we
see in large parts of the world maybe
not in Barcelona and in Hong Kong
because there is different motives
behind there the protest is that it's a
return of the social question in
combination with corruption basically
and this is like a very explosive
mixture basically you have a certain
fertile ground that is the grievances of
people that that that are the losers
let's say of globalization and then
there's this transformative events
they're called in social movement
research basically that you know make
blatantly obvious the the disparities
between the walk-and-talk of the elite
basically and that that show blatantly
obvious to everyone that those in power
and not you know managing the country
for their good for the people's good but
for their own in a way and I think that
the cases that were mentioned here are
obviously examples for that but you
could as well add Indonesia to that or
you could add Peru to that we're
actually attempts to disempower
anti-corruption agencies and so on where
the trigger for protests it's this
motive of corruption is returning over
and over and over in this protest so I
think this is one of the most common
denominators of these protests across
the world basically Rick you have been
writing on these sales same questions
what have you discovered
well what I think we have discovered as
is essentially what you just sent sort
of the this inequality social discontent
is certainly driving tensions in a lot
of countries but then at the same time I
think one of the more interesting
discoveries is sort of how people have
been trying to deal with it on how
they've responded to this and one
interesting example I've seen over the
last few days has actually been Chile
where people have realised that with
this government and they might not be
able to achieve what they want which is
a new constitution essentially and
they've come together in thousands of
sort of small town hall meetings which
they've organized themselves or that
have been organized by by soccer clubs
or other institutions where they
themselves have tried to develop
solutions and and I think those
initiatives and those those ideas are
quite interesting to observe and and
they're happening in a number of
countries
okay so community and equality are very
important issues very important tropes
in what is going on how much and you
mentioned this earlier agita how much is
this it is this an age war well it is
pretty much in a drawer because the gap
between rich and poor is widening all
over the world or in a lot of countries
even in the United States and even in
communities in Europe it's not widening
to the same degree as in many other
countries what we're seeing in the
protests like and shield Chile is one of
the most you know is one of the richest
latin-american countries huge inequality
but the inequality is massive in it
and the same I mean we were talking
about the Sheila John protests protests
in France who are those people who were
protesting a lot of them were people
from the barrio who are of immigrant
descents or Algerians who went to Paris
I mean if you go to Paris now and you
cross the you cross to the value in the
metro and the underground you
immediately know that you arrived to the
volunteer because I mean you can tell
when you walk on the street that it's
the value because it's it's been left
you know to to to decay I mean it's
collapsing you can tell that people are
unemployed people don't know what to do
it's the social inequality is massive
there and well the same goes in Lebanon
and Iraq those are two countries that
don't have electricity I mean Iraq is an
old rich country that people don't have
electricity now and the same in Lebanon
I mean it's yeah the the level of you
know difference between rich and poor is
widening and it's scary and poor people
can not put up with it even if you tell
them it's 20 cent on the phone call when
you are the country that pays them you
know that one of the highest builds on
cellular phones and you know you come
and strip them this right of making a
free call that's been given to them it's
a universal you know is that they are
gonna get angry and they are gonna go on
the streets and you know things lead to
other things yes yeah I think it's
completely it's completely right what
you just said and and I mean what turns
these I mean you you could have you know
discontent with a political system in
any part of the world but and yeah you
certainly have that in democracies as
well you know um you have protests all
over the place but what I think turns
these discourage her tests into larger
social movements and to larger mass
uprisings if you will is that there's a
there's a frustration basically me the
mechanisms or visit with with a lack of
responsibility of the political systems
where these protest takes place so
people on the street and and there
there's a parallel actually with with
movements like extinction rebellion in
Germany where where the people on the
street they have no trust anymore that
the political systems that are in place
to govern them basically can provide
solutions for the problems that they see
and to water climate to what extent when
you talk about that kind of frustration
to what extent can
can violence even be the way to bring
about change to what extent is that
acceptable after all we're sitting here
in Germany the countries that are so
proud of its peaceful revolution that
removed the Berlin Wall I mean I mean
first of all I think it's necessary to
differ basically what kind of violence
we're talking about if we're talking
about physical violence and like on you
know violence or structural violence
which is basically the mind driver that
brings people to the street there in the
first place when we talk about physical
violence at protest events themselves
sometimes also in response to policing
measures then there is there's basically
the the evidence is mixed in research
there's there's there's been you know
there's very there's a there's very luck
very little evidence that suggests that
violent revolutions are generally more
successful than non-violent ones and the
opposite is not true as well there's
been a very contentious book Bearcat
Genoa that came out lately that
basically contested these theses of the
nonviolent revolution as the most
successful way I think in a way it's not
steerable anyway that that much often
these violent incidents happen out of
situational dynamics where things go out
of hand in in Lebanon yesterday a
protester was shot and killed overnight
this might very well be an event that
spirals out of control in Hong Kong a
protester was shot in a melee with
police on the street this was certainly
not planned premeditated but this this
stuff can can you know trigger spirals
that that end up in violent uprisings at
one point so I think that there's a
limited ability of social movements to
control their followers to a certain
extent they're doing that and I think
it's remarkable that actually most of
these protests are nonviolent right now
and it's still remarkably peaceful in a
way these lights to express them
sometimes I just want to say that one of
the reasons why those protests or you
know some of them are turning into
violence is that the international order
is kind of broken down I mean we have
the United States that is the leader of
the world that that's been quiet on most
of those things or most of those
conflicts I mean very important point
because it had for so long been a
flagship of freedom yeah wait for the
United States to see what they have to
say about those conflicts and when the
United
is not saying anything is not calling
for the government in Iraq - you know
reform is not calling on the government
of Lebanon to listen to the people is
not you know when we have this silence
so those governments feel empowered to
fight back that people and this will
obviously lead to violence because the
people feel they're not being heard and
they want to escape it and you know
that's when things get out of control
interesting comments now let's have a
look in our two countries that have gone
in different directions in recent times
change worte din one of the countries
changed to a certain extent at least
realized in the other the 2011 Arab
Spring began in Tunisia and spread to
Egypt after weeks of protests Egyptian
President Hosni Mubarak resigned he
ruled for nearly 30 years he was tried
on corruption charges newly elected
Egyptian president Mohamed Mursi
set about establishing a strict
religious regime after one year he was
ousted by a military coup in 2014 former
defense minister el Sisi became
president he ordered thousands arrested
and democratic organizations crushed
many Egyptians are calling the regime
worse than Mubarak's and they're taking
to the streets a ray of hope appeared in
Sudan after over three decades of
ruthless domination and months of
protests Sudanese dictator Omar
al-bashir was ousted by the country's
military following continued bloodshed
the military council and opposition
forces for freedom movement signed an
agreement regulating the division of
power between military and civilian
Authority the first democratic elections
are to be held within three years is it
the military that decides success or
failure of a revolution
big the important question another
require question that is related to that
young as you are smiling a little bit
it's a very broad question I'd like to
give you how do you how do you best move
from anger and despair to sustained
constructive change I get that that's
the one million dollar question I know
it in a way right I mean that's that's
the holy grail of transition studies in
a way that's no guarantee for success
but those cases that have proven
successful arm transitional countries
are to make their way towards
democratization or to more open and more
liberal systems of society or
post-conflict countries such as Lebanon
or Iraq dialogue basically and
roundtables and bringing the
stakeholders to the table and not only
those with the guns basically has proven
like a relatively successful recipe to
to married mediate conflict and and and
to keep it keep it peaceful now where
exclusion never works on the long run it
might work for a time but repression
repression actually remarks we work
remarkably well for a certain time but
it might backfire on the long run so
this exclusion I don't have much hope
that wherever people are excluded that
this will be sustainable what role does
leadership play in all this I've seen
you know one comment with we're
experiencing at the moment a new age of
leaderless revolution as though that was
something to be applauded as though that
were a good thing but what happened to
Mahatma Gandhi what happened to Martin
Luther King what happened to Nelson
Mandela these are the kind of people
surely that these movements could use
right I guess the sort of advantage or
what what people see is the advantage of
leaderless movements is that it can't be
so easily perhaps abused by someone who
is charismatic or wants to steer protest
in in a certain movement but the risk of
course is as similar that it can derail
and and perhaps people are no longer
quite sure what they wanted to achieve
in the first place and then certain
elements break out and and violence
erupts as some afeared and in hong kong
for instance what is interesting though
is that in a lot of those places where
protests have
been happening for instance in Iraq on
Tahrir Square or in Lebanon people have
sort of come together on public spaces
and try to create a society they they
sort of envision in a small micro scale
and that is something really interesting
I think because that is essentially
leadership by by living it and by by
showing the elite and the establishment
what they have in mind
you touched on the leadership earlier
yeah that's true because one of the main
problems now is that the whoever is in
power does not want to give power this
is what you know and believe you when
the president left and you know went to
Mexico this didn't even come down
because this step came came came late
because what he tried to do is that he
tried to run for another election he
rigged the election he won the election
he stayed in power and this is what to
give the people and we see that yeah of
course if you want to stay in power and
if you want to stop those protests
against you by force what will happen we
had an example in Syria president
Michele as I attempted to or did that
with the help of the Russians which made
things worse but what's happened to
Syria now I mean Syria now is a
fractured country is a country that
would if the war ends now would take
decades to recover and you know God
knows how many refugees are going to be
able to return to their country if that
happens so you can stay in power and you
can't crush the revolution but at what
price at the price of losing your
country as it is yes I've got a quote
for you which I found a very extremely
interesting this week I was reading a so
a common commentator from the Center for
Strategic and International Studies in
Washington he wrote the risks and
implications are mounting for
governments businesses and organizations
it's a question of when and not if the
digital flash mob comes to those in
power how much should the those in power
be fearing the mob well I think that
those in power have always feared the
mob what they're feeling now is social
media basically I mean that that what's
this quote also alleges to you basically
that you know the digital connections
that can be drawn between very you know
disparate people and and and also
outside of this big urban center
basically this is a very empowering
component of social media that's also
why so many in power trying to control
social media and they're employing you
know bot armies and they're using
sophisticated means of digital
surveillance and repression to get to
those that organize protest and so on so
I think it's a two-edged sword it's
basically a continuation of I think the
game that has been going on between the
people and power holders authoritarian
ones for decades just that now a digital
level a digital arena has been added to
that basically oh we're running out of
time we're gonna have to leave it there
I'm afraid we've been talking about this
global uprising here on to the point
thanks very much for joining us
until next week bye bye and chest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you